1200 times more likely that a child is
going to be killed if they're in the
household with one parent that isn't a
biological parent ancestrally we maybe
don't have tons of evidence that we're a
monogamous species therefore monogamy is
not the strategy That was supposed to go
down if you accept the fact that
non-monogamous societies are more
unstable and are going to exist for a
lesser amount of time that means that
the living standards are going to be
lower that means that mortality all of
the things that you care about right are
going to be out of the window maybe a
different way to frame monogamy is that
it's kind of like following the law a
little bit it's a small individual
sacrifice that you make that does
perhaps make for some people sub-optimal
living standards but only a little bit
but the reason that you do that is to
contribute to the entire stability of
society I've heard monogamy referred to
as sexual socialism they're good
outcomes also in terms of things like
child abuse and domestic violence which
obviously is something feminists are
very interested in like polygonist
societies have much higher rates of both
because households with multiple wives
and their children are like full of
conflict